für diese Staffel 7 vs white war der
Helikopter drop off als Highlight schon
früh geplant um zu schauen ob das
grundsätzlich möglich ist und außerdem
sicherzustellen dass dabei keiner der
Teilnehmer zu Schaden kommt oder dies
schon Monate Voraussetzung ausgiebig
geplant getestet und optimiert warum der
Helikopter drop off und damit auch die
gesamte Staffel 2 trotzdem wenige
Stunden Voraussetzung gefährdet war
erfahrt ihr in dieser Folge von Seven vs
wild behind the scenes
die heutige Folge wird euch präsentiert
von Adobe Creative Cloud worauf ich
unheimlich stolz bin dieses Projekt und
alle weiteren Projekt auf meinem Kanal
entstehen mit Adobe Programm und Sie
sind unser tägliches Werkzeug adobe
bietet mit Creative Cloud über 20
Desktop Programme mobile Apps und Online
Services umso ziemlich alles was ihr
euch vorstellen könnt am Medien zu
gestalten aufzunehmen oder
nachzubearbeiten ohne Creative Cloud
würde dieses Projekte Faktor so nicht
entstehen kann in der Bearbeitung einer
Folge so wie ihr sie gerade seht
sortieren und schneiden wir erst alle
einzelnen Aufnahmen im Premiere Pro
wechseln im Prozess immer wieder in
After Effects um genau solche Sachen
hier zu animieren und nehmen dann
Erklärung und Moderation in nordischen
auf das Thumbnail also dieses kleine
Bildchen auf dass sie klickt um ein
Video auszuwählen geht erst in Lightroom
grundsätzlich bearbeitet Helligkeit
Kontrast Farben und so weiter um es dann
in Photoshop in mühevoller Kleinarbeit
zu finalisieren also wirklich unsere
Arbeit beruht von vorne bis hinten jeden
Tag auf den Creative club-programm um
euch die Möglichkeit zu geben auch
solche Projekte umzusetzen oder euch
einfach mal kreativ auszuleben gibt es
aktuell ein Angebot in dem Studenten 20%
auf die eh schon um 65 rabattierte
Studentenversion sparen Privatanwender
gehen aber natürlich auch nicht leer aus
und bekommen 40% auf den regulären Preis
also seid schnell klickt auf die Links
in der Videobeschreibung oder im PIN
comment und fangt an kreativ zu werden
was jetzt kommt ist nicht mit Adobe
abgesprochen ich wollte es aber trotzdem
einmal sagen alle Leute um mich rum auch
die Jungs die jetzt für mich dieses
behind the scenes mit mir gemeinsam
schneiden sind einfach mit irgendeinem
Rechner und den Programmen der Creative
Cloud gestartet und jetzt sitzen wir
hier und können so ein riesen Projekt
schneiden und so viele Leute unterhalten
das wäre ohne diese Programme nicht
möglich gewesen deswegen das so
unheimlich besonders für mich ist jetzt
mit Adobe zusammen zu arbeiten also
vielen Dank für die Zusammenarbeit
vielen Dank für all eure Programme und
allen Zuschauern jetzt viel Spaß mit dem
Video Check die Links in der
Videobeschreibung aus und fangt an damit
irgendwas zu machen das ist hammergeil 4
Tage voraussetzung ist ein Teil des
Teams noch mal zum hange gefahren um
alle weiteren Piloten mit ihrem Plänen
und Erkenntnissen zu Briefen kurz zu
Einordnung wir sitzen gerade im Hangar
von dem aus die Helikopter starten
werden bei der Aussetzung und ohne unser
Wissen hat der Carlos das hier unser
Ansprechpartner für die Helikopter und
so
die Hitze Ministerin für
Tourismus eingeladen die einfach da im
Hangar stand mit irgendwelchen Leuten im
Militär gewandt Uniform die man erstmal
nicht so zuordnen konnte hat sich dann
rausgestellt das war waren Generäle von
Aero naval also der Küstenwache und dem
Militär aus Panama und dann war auch
noch der Chef der Panama Klinik da vor
Ort die sich alle dort eingefunden
hatten um absurderweise unser Projekt zu
unterstützen ja und jetzt müssen wir den
da irgendwie verklickern dass wir Leute
aus dem Helikopter schmeißen wollen dass
sie da ganz alleine sind dass wir im
Zweifel dann vielleicht irgendwie
Helikopter nachts angeflogen obwohl nach
Flugverbot herrscht dann Panama auf
jeden Fall jetzt wird hier einfach nur
ein bisschen getalkt man macht sich
bekannt miteinander weil in Panama und
generell ich sag mal mit Amerika
Südamerika läuft einfach viel darüber
wie man persönlich zu kennen
persönlichen Kontakt zu kriegen dann
sind die Leute sehr sehr viel
Lebensberater als man einfach sagt ja da
kommt so eine Produktion aus Deutschland
und die machen irgendwie
das schon deutlich besser wenn man den
mal die Hand geschüttelt hat den in die
Augen geguckt hat dann sind die in der
Regel sehr sehr viel Bereiter sich zu
bewegen Sachen möglich zu machen
ja dann irgendwie
mit ungeduscht einfach in den Hangar zu
stapfen auf einmal steht da so eine
staatskolonne und irgendwelche Leute die
nicht kennst die aber einfach wichtig
sind in diesem Land so das ist halt
einfach verrückt ne so jetzt haben wir
aufgereiht die wichtigsten Leute für die
Orga inklusive der Vize Ministerin für
Tourismus mittendrin Paddy Martin und
Tom in der Regel dieser ja wie schon
sagen wichtige Menschen in Panama und
die haben uns Unterstützung zugesichert
haben gesagt es ist cool finden dass sie
hoffen dass Panama gut repräsentiert
wird dass wir uns unterstützen geht
wieder Art okay neue Info und zwar haben
wir die Unterstützung von Militär von
der Luftwaffe die stellen uns
zusätzliche Helikopter zur Verfügung und
stationären Boot in der Nähe das
durchgehend auf Bereitschaft ist quasi
bedeutet in dem Fall von einem extrem
Notfall wo nicht geflogen werden kann
also zum Beispiel Tropensturm Hurricane
sonst irgendwas dann haben wir ein
militärboot vor Ort dass eine
Evakuierung nach Panama City durchführen
kann das ist irgendwie
beängstigend und auch ein bisschen cool
nachdem mit den Helikopter Piloten alles
geklärt wurde und der Produktion die
militärische Unterstützung von aeroner
Wald zugesichert wurde konnte das Team
die Teilnehmer einige Tage später guten
Gewissens anreisen lassen
[Musik]
während die Teilnehmer von einem Teil
des Teams in Panama City gebrieft wurden
haben sich die verbleibenden
Teammitglieder währenddessen auf der
Insel um das Aussetzen und platzieren
der drybex an den Spots der Teilnehmer
gekümmert
nach einem Weg zu den Teilnehmern
morgen früh bis dann richtig richtig
ernst ja gucken uns alles was noch mal
an
Sechser aus
und dann geht's los genau für solche
Animationen nutzen wir After Effects von
Adobe Creative Cloud deswegen hier noch
mal die Erinnerung über die ersten
beiden Links in der Videobeschreibung
findet ihr das Angebot ich wünsche euch
damit viel Spaß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am Baum platziert
[Musik]
instagram
Alter der Kirche Beach medienteil hier
and we are going back in this there that
you readies
[Musik]
okay tschüss
und nach all den strapazzen einer Menge
Gespräche und viel Kopfzerbrechen waren
tatsächlich alle Vorbereitungen
getroffen und dem großen Tag der
Aussetzung stand nichts mehr im Wege
wenn ich das währenddessen gefällt und
die uns unterstützen wollt dann vergesst
nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren um keinen
der weiteren Folgen zu verpassen das war
schon der Mittag am Tag davor und ich
sagte noch das läuft alles wie am
Schnürchen hier wir haben nur noch den
drop of tomorrow mehr kann ja eigentlich
nicht schief gehen
so dass wir die ganze Zeit gesagt haben
irgendwo kommt der Körper noch irgendwas
läuft doch nicht so mittendrin ich
glaube es war das Briefing von Thorsten
gab es einen Anruf von der
helikoptergesellschaft mit dem wir hier
diese Insel geflogen sind
für uns
komm bitte kurz rein weg von den
Teilnehmern ich muss euch was sagen er
hat am Telefon erfahren der Job auf ist
abgesagt 15 Stunden vor drop of
also ist tatsächlich gerade richtig
scheiße irgendein komischer Inspektor
sitzt da gerade mit dem Chef von der
Luftlinie da in der Leitung und macht
das trouble ab in ubersetzen hin zum
Hangar direkt mit den Leuten vor Ort
reden was ist hier gerade das Problem
so wir sind wieder am Hangar wir haben
jetzt gerade was war das wo wir zwei
Stunden diskutiert denn alles was wir
seit drei Monaten besprechen mit den
Helikopter Piloten ist jetzt nicht mehr
möglich seit sechs Monaten fragen wir
die Piloten mit allem was uns einfällt
geht das geht das haben wir genug Sprit
haben wir genug Zeit time geht das alles
ist immer ja ja ja das geht und haben
Vortag des Abflugs kriegen wir den Anruf
das geht alles gar nicht so wir haben
ein großes Glück glaube ich dass sie
gezwungen sind kompromissbereit zu sein
dadurch dass wir die diese 14 Ministerin
und so weiter im Rücken haben ich glaube
sonst würde sich hier gar nichts bewegen
also das wäre den scheiß egal bitte
nicht so richtig Wort für den Kopf
platzt also das ist nicht zu glauben
unser ursprüngliche Plan war dass wir
mit drei hier kommt dann aus Panama City
rüber zu Island fliegen und dort die
Teilnehmer aussetzen das ganze war
ungefähr berechnet mit zweieinhalb
Stunden Flugzeit also halbe Stunde hin
dann ein Job auf wird jede Copter
eineinhalb Stunden plus halbe Stunde
zurück zweieinhalb Stunden run Award und
wurde von Anfang an gesagt die
Helikopter haben eine fly time von 4
Stunden so dass wir auch so kalkuliert
haben und heute ein Tag vor Job off
Kriminal anrufen dass die mit anderthalb
Stunden vielleicht Scheiben kalkulieren
statt 4 wir wollten unbedingt die
Teilnehmer Helikopter auch für eine
Türen haben damit wir vernünftig filmen
können und dann einfach für dieses
Gefühl hat vorne okay wir fliegen jetzt
hier wird offenen Tür durch den
Dschungel also einfach geiler das
Problem ist die Aerodynamik verändert
sich dadurch wird die Geschwindigkeit
der Helikopter reduziert und wenn ihr
hier langsamer fliegen verbrauchen sie
im Verhältnisse mehr Sprit durch die
Türen die nicht mehr da sind wird also
der spritverbraucht jetzt hatten wir
dann die Optionen durchgesprochen dass
wir gesagt haben okay dann packen wir
die Türen rein dann springen die Leute
halt raus machen die Tür auf Tür wieder
zu damit wir den Spritverbrauch
reduzieren das ging aber auch jetzt
nicht mehr obwohl es im Test drangehen
von einem halben Jahr das immer
funktioniert jetzt geht das nicht mehr
aber Sicherheitsgründen angeblich mag
kein Problem von einem halben Jahr war
kein Problem vor drei Tagen heißt jetzt
haben wir uns für Lösungen entschieden
und wir hoffen dass es noch ich glaube
das funktioniert dass wir inzwischen
Lösung machen und die Alternative ist
dass wir die Teilnehmer vorher mit einer
kleinen Maschine überfliegen
ja sowas dann warten da ihre CD bekommt
da und die landen vorher auf San Jose
zwischen dem Flugzeug und dann steigen
Sie unbedingt den Kopf da und dann
machen wir die geplante Prozedur es ist
nicht ideal heißt aber dass die
Helikopter mit geschlossenen Türen und
Benzinkanister zur Insel fliegen können
heißt sie brauchen weniger Sprit und sie
haben noch reserbetan dabei können auf
der Insel die Türen abnehmen können dann
den Job aufmachen und dann wieder auf
sein landen die Türen wieder reinsetzen
vielleicht noch mal volltanken und dann
wieder abwachsen das ist jetzt unsere
Idee wir wissen noch nicht ob es
funktioniert das ist aus meiner Sicht
aber die beste Alternative die wir haben
hoffe dass es klappt
[Musik]
nächstes Update man sieht es ist schon
dunkel geworden wir sind immer noch im
Hangar wir wissen immer noch nicht ob
der Job auf stattfinden kann die geplant
und wir haben theoretisch der Lösung
gefunden aber die ist jetzt halt teurer
12 14 Stunden oder sowas bis der Drop
auf stattfinden soll und wir bis jetzt
noch eine Preisverhandlung gehen
wieder mal ein Update aus Manga wir
haben weiter diskutiert
reiseverhandelt die Situation vorhandelt
was war besten Schuld Werte was wie
machen müssen wenn des Tages haben sie
gesagt das war ihr schuld sind heilig
berührt natürlich aber wir sind jetzt in
einigen gekommen ist okay ist nicht cool
das ist nicht geil es gibt aktuell kein
Plan B
immer noch im Hangar wieder eine Stunde
später so langsam dämmert mir warum die
aller allermeistenste waldproduktion
Fake sind wir sind angewiesen darauf auf
die Leute die können sich jetzt
irgendwelche Fantasiepreise ausdenken
und wir sind im Prinzip gezwungen diese
Preise zu bezahlen weil was wollen wir
machen wir mieten jetzt noch drei
Flugzeuge das ist der Workaround jetzt
für die Probleme die aufgetaucht sind
das ist eines der drei Flugzeuge dann
gibt's noch ein Tankflugzeug und noch
ein Transportflugzeug ich melde mich
zurück wenn wir hier alles geklärt haben
okay Finales Update wir werden jetzt in
einer verlassen und morgen früh wieder
zurückkehren ist wird vermutlich in
einigen Stunden werde ich vielleicht
darüber lachen können und vielleicht
wird es jetzt für euch auch gar nicht so
dramatisch aber also für uns ist es
dramatisch aber man muss auch sagen wenn
es darum geht dann Lösung zu finden da
haben wir auch einfach die besten am
Start mit Paddy Tom Martin also wenn man
das in so einer Lage kommen wird dann
mit den Jungs also
mir vielleicht mitbekommen habe es gab
einige Planänderungen jetzt
ich werde jetzt no story short machen um
6 Uhr das letzte Mal Hotel hier in
Panama City Job auf beginnt let's go
WiFi karaza Conny Snickers
oh nee was ist denn das oh nee Alter ein
Motorrad
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Flugzeug Flugzeug
jeder fliegt alleine
beginnt ihr muss einmal noch kurz zum
Unterschreiben wir regeln in der Zeit
irgendwo alles mit dem Essen und dann
geht's gleich weiter
Dave kannst du dir gleich noch mal von
allen so ein shot holen wo die sagen ich
mache das hier alles freiwillig
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen schön dass Ihr da
seid ihr werdet gleich ausgesetzt bevor
es losgeht haben wir noch eine kleine
Videobotschaft für euch Angela Merkel es
kommt Teilnehmer aus der ersten Staffel
boah
[Applaus]
letzte Worte
Fingers Cross das keiner sich umbringt
ich bin jetzt Cross dass keine
verunglückt beim Aussetzen so weiter wie
ich richtig am Arsch
und ich ziehe mir jetzt rein weil ich
bin übrigens
das wird die größte Challenge meines
Lebens und glaubt für einige da drinne
auch
unfassbar es ist unfassbar
durch einmal hallo hallo ich mache
nämlich auch mit
dieses Jahr
[Musik]
Geist finde
das ist deine lieblingsspinne
gar nicht vollkommen ungefährlich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im Wald runter
ich war dann im Urwald
[Gelächter]
es ist nicht bestätigt aber eine die
kopf-pilot hat gesagt er hat hier auf
der Insel die Pferde rausgesehen die
Lanzen
musst du weg
da die ganzen Otter ist wirklich
so das ist die letzte drecksauger
auf der Insel wir unschwer erkennen
könnt werde gleich mit Helikopter
ausgesetzt das bedeutet es gibt jetzt
noch einmal ein finales Briefing für
euch wie ihr sicher rausspringt damit
kein Fleisch gibt
hier wird unsere Arbeit auf gleich fängt
eure an wenn ihr jetzt einmal eure Köpfe
dreht ihr seht drei Helikopter es gibt
ein gewisse karenzte Kulanz die wir
haben werden hier nicht springt fliegen
wir weiter ihr kriegt noch eine zweite
Chance so sieht das dann aus wenn ihr da
drin sitzt in jedem der Helikopter ist
ein koordinater für uns du kriegst von
deinem Koordinator das Finale go zum
Absprung wenn du das hast du dich ab
alles klar du hast go
genau einmal aufsteigen
wie hoch wird das in etwas sein variiert
je nach Spot wie ist es mit nackt nackt
rein schwimmen
wichtig wenn ihr ins Wasser geübt seid
es ist schwer zu sagen ob es euch gut
oder schlecht geht es gibt ein wichtiges
Zeichen das hätte man machen können das
stimmt ist einfach ist einfach so ja das
sagt euch jeder Koordinator noch mal
bevor ihr springen ja es gibt noch einen
dritten Helikopter da sind einmal Kamera
Leute drin das sind unsere Sanis drin da
ist der Islam drin und ich bin da drin
ich bin euer Rettungsschwimmer wenn ich
merke dass einer von euch wirklich in
Not gerät und ihr rausgezogen werden
müssen dann springe ich hinterher und
wir sehen zu dass wir zu zweit an Land
kommen zusammengefasst wir starten
gleich mit drei Helikoptern hier gibt
das Okay zeichnen wenn alles gut ist ihr
geht an den Strand sucht eure Ausrüstung
und schickt mit dem Garmin den ersten
Code green und dann sind wir auf uns
selbst überlassen kann
jetzt natürlich wie gestern auch noch
einmal bitte unterschreiben dass wenn
ihr den runter springt dass eure Schuld
ist so jetzt brauchen wir noch ein paar
motivierende Worte für die nächsten 7
Tage von dir nein
Leute wir sind die Kandidaten der
zweiten Staffel von Sarah Wilds es geht
um alles ich weiß dass wir es alles
schaffen können der Mensch ist zu allem
viel jeder von euch kann über sich
hinauswachsen völlig egal wir werden 7
Tage auf alles verzichten was wir lieben
aber kommen stärker mit einem neuen
mindset wieder zurück schaffen wir das
dann gib mir ein ja ja
[Musik]
was könnte jetzt noch schief gehen
da sollten wir uns mal wieder ihren
[Musik]